Russian soldiers whose
comrades are dying in mass
are tonight appealing
directly to the Russian
president for help
the man who refuse to address
our command has replenished
our unit with new mobilized.
Six times now.
This is evidence of the incompetence
of our superiors and of the whole unit.
Please help.
There is nowhere else to turn.
Just just to break that down.
These mobilized men are saying
that their unit has been replenished
six times.
Think about all that death.
It is horrific.
And what is most significant
about this appeal
is that they directly, as mobilized men,
are calling their commanders incompetent
and directing that entire thing,
not just a telegram for a random post
directly to Putin. For him to see it.
And it comes as we have more video
of another
Russian soldier
calling the situation
on the ground in eastern Ukraine,
a cluster of
we found that
our tank is burning over there.
So please
be greetings to everyone
straight from the front line,
firsthand evidence
of what's happening here It is a cluster,
but we are pushing holy
glory to Russia.
These damning videos coming is inside
Russia itself.
The brutal Wagner group
is purportedly
turning to students from Moscow
in order to fill its ranks.
Now, we understand that
the students in question
here are in 10th grade.
And I want to emphasize
the significance
of the fact
that these boys are in Moscow,
which is the region that has sent
the least fighters to the front line,
the region that has been kept
the most isolated
from the effects of the war
where more elite live.
This is the video of what's
believed to be a Wagner fighter.
His face is covered.
He's in a classroom
and he is lecturing
students on so-called contract service.
Now, the students were forced
to fill out.
We understand
this survey is showing it to you
on the screen.
It asks for their personal information.
Also,
the contact information of their parents
also asks,
do you have any relatives
who are living in hostile countries
and what is your level
of physical fitness?
Do you possess any basic military skills
and those are elaborated
as tactical first aid or shooting.
I want to mention CNN
cannot independently verify the claims,
but this push for more recruits
for the Wagner group,
not even the Russian formal
military, comes as Putin
is continuing to crack down on dissent.
Today, a former
top deputy
of jailed opposition leader Alexei
Navalny appeared in a Russian courtroom.
Her name is Lilia trying to save her.
She's already been in jail for a year
and faces another 18 years if convicted.
After opening a regional headquarters
for Navalny's anti-corruption foundation,
that foundation has uncovered
example after example
after example of corruption
from Putin and his inner circle.
OUTFRONT now
and of ADUDA,
the vice
president of Alexi Navalny's
anti-corruption foundation
and a former spokesperson for Navalny.
And Anna,
I very much appreciate your time.
Do you believe
there is any way
that Liliya will avoid an 18 year
sentence here?
Well, unfortunately, we don't have
any evidence
that would suggest
that she would avoid that
because the way
she would have been treated
for all this time,
the way the two have been put into this
detention center,
instead of being under house arrest,
for example,
because this is the measure
which is implied when
the prosecutors are afraid that
the person will try to escape the country
to try to escape the justice.
But Lilia is on the opposite.
She was always very vocal about her
staying in Russia and not going anywhere
and not leaving her country
and not live in her region.
So this, this, only this.
And then
the fact that she is not allowed
she was not allowed to talk to her
parents on the phone,
not to have visits
with them, with her parents
and with her husband
for all the 16 months behind the bars.
So we do think
that they will be harsh on her.
And this is
why they have been so harsh on her,
because she's a very talented
opposition politician.
She was very effective in
what she was doing
and she was very successful
in gathering rails
against the corruption encouraged
she was investigating corruption
of the officials encouraging.
She was a very effective manager
of the headquarters
of the regional campaign in fact.
And I know that this of course,
her situation right now is coming
ahead of you know,
Navalny is again
I used the word trial
with with great quotation marks
is coming up as well.
And he is currently
in solitary confinement
in a maximum security
Russian penal colony.
His recent tweet and was
which I want to be clear to everybody
when I say this, he can't tweet is
when he's able to get a message out
and someone else
can put that tweet out for him.
It was the main torment of imprisonment
is, of course, the inability
to see the faces of your family
to talk to your loved ones.
I haven't had any visit for eight months.
And yesterday I was told
I'd be transferred
to a cell type facility
for the maximum
possible term of six months.
So he says he wouldn't have had a visitor
then for a year.
Of course, his health is suffering.
And now now he's got this other trial.
I mean, do you believe that
you'll see him out of jail alive?
Of course
I believe
I will see him out of jail life.
But we also understand
that his sentence is a life
sentence in terms
that it's either
his life sentence or Putin's.
So as long as Putin is in the office,
Navalny will not sit them.
But we do believe that we will see him
free one day
and we will get the Putin
out of Kremlin and,
of course, out of Ukraine.
And I know, Anna, obviously,
you know Lilia very well.
And she made the decision to stay.
I know if you were to go back
now, you would be arrested.
You can't go back.
You know you know, what would await you
at this point?
Are there are there others
who are still continuing to try
to stay in Russia
and continue this fight?
Of course, there's a lot of people
there are still people
who are protesting against the war
right now in Russia.
And there are a lot of people
in detention, political prisoners
who have been protesting,
who have been opposing this.
This government ended this war.
Of course, a lot of people decide to stay
and they
they do it for the reason
that it's their country.
And they don't intend to leave it.
They don't intend to
you know,
leave it
in the hands of these bandits
and Kremlin.
And they are trying to
they're waiting for
the time to
to be free,
to make Russia free and great again.
All right.
Well, and I thank you very much.
I appreciate your time coming out
and speaking
about about your friends
and your colleagues
who you know so well
who are suffering through this.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for not only.